RAPH LEVIEN: I'm
Raph Levien, and I'm
on the Android UI Toolkit team.
And, I'm going to
talk to you today
about Android textual layout.
And I hope you'll find
this an interesting talk,
and I hope you brought
lots of questions as well.
And I'm happy to try to address
those after the session,
and also at office
hours this afternoon.
So I'm going to talk
about-- it's kind
a grab bag of a bunch of
different topics around text
and typography on Android.
I'm going to talk about
some of the challenges
and opportunities.
Just a little bit of an
introduction to material
design, which I'm sure everybody
here is quite familiar with.
Then I'm going to go into some
of the details about the Roboto
2.0 and Noto fonts,
and especially
the kind of more recent
changes around these
to better support
international typography.
A huge amount of the work that
we do on the Android UI Toolkit
team is supporting all of
the languages of the world,
or most of them.
Then I'm going to go into
some of the really, I think,
exciting newer features around
open type typography control,
and high-quality
paragraph layout,
which rolled out in
Lollipop and Marshmallow .
So what are some of the
challenges and opportunities?
I mean, I come from
a print background.
And doing typography
on mobile is
extremely different than
doing typography in print.
There are some things in common,
but there are some things
that are really different.
You have to be very focused
on the performance of the text
stack, because you've got
only so much battery and only
so much RAM.
But you really do have very
powerful compute resources.
You've got multi-core,
multi-gigahertz processes
in there.
So if you want to do
sophisticated, advanced
typography, you do have the
compute power to do that.
60 frames a second is
absolutely a requirement.
And this is, again, both a
challenge and an opportunity.
That you can do these
really rich animations,
and transitions and do this
kind of interactive motion
typography that
really is completely
impossible in a
print background.
But you have to
make everything fit
in that 16-millisecond budget.
You've got a very small screen.
And this has some
interesting challenges
in how you create
your layouts, how
you do the paragraph layout.
But a flip side, again,
is that on modern devices
you have this very
high resolution.
Then, as I mentioned,
we have this requirement
to support all of the
languages of the world, all
of the scripts of the world.
But we have a lot of
really good resources
both in fonts and typography
control of how you do that.
And then I'm going
to talk about some
of the line-breaking
improvements, some
of the paragraph-improvements
in Marshmallow.
And those were really
motivated by a need
to get this working in very
small screens like watch faces.
So I'm going to just
kind of introduce
this concept of the advance
of display technology.
This was the first
mobile device I ever
had when I was 12 years old.
And I mean, as you
can see, it's got
a lot of the elements of
a modern mobile device.
It even has a really
nice big keyboard.
But the display technology in
this generation of technology
is kind of the bare
minimum that you need
to get text displayed at all.
And I think that that
evolution kind of carried
that there was a very
primitive approach
to just get that the
letters drawn on the screen,
and not really think
about typography.
Another good thing
about this screenshot
is you get some sense of the
difference in computing power
available today as back then.
So you know before
I worked on Android,
I was working on Google
web fonts, Google Fonts.
And the upper left corner is
kind of your classic laptop
or desktop screen.
And this really
ruled what we did.
That you have a very
small number of pixels
to represent the text.
And you have a
lot of constraints
in how the letter-forms
map into those pixels.
And that also
includes the spacing.
You see very poor-- the A and
P are crunched up together,
and the P and O are
separated, because you only
have so many pixels
and so much precision.
But as you go into more
modern display technology,
you have so many more pixels.
And so on the upper right,
you have a 4K monitor, which
is starting to replace laptops.
And on the lower
left, this isn't even
the most recent device.
This is a two-year-old
device and it has 468 ppi.
And you probably can't
even see the pixels here.
And then comparing that to,
for example, an inkjet printer,
you actually have-- on
these mobile devices,
you have a much higher
precision, higher quality
representation of the
shapes of the letter forms
and the spaces between them.
So it really enables typography.
And all four of these
screen shots or captures
are of the same
12-point Times Roman.
And so this is what we
have to work with today.
This is our lead device.
The Nexus 6P.
It's an Amazing device, and
it has an amazing screen
to match the overall device.
It's 515 ppi.
One of the ways I think
about screen resolution
is when "Star Trek"-- when they
were doing the "Star Trek" TV
show, they had a book that
had all of the specifications
for all the technology,
like how many terajoules
were in a phaser pulse.
And one of the
specifications is,
what is the resolution
of these little devices
that people are carrying around?
And the answer is 400 dpi.
So we've blown way
past "Star Trek".
So I mean, as I
say, everybody here
knows about material design.
This'll just touch on it.
That the UX Team-- it started
really about two years ago
that they were looking at these
kind of more powerful devices,
higher-quality
display technologies.
And they were really thinking,
if we were redesigning this
from scratch-- if we
really could do anything,
what would we do?
And the result of
that exploration
really synthesized into
a set of guidelines,
into a coherent design
language that incorporates
many different elements.
It incorporates colors.
It incorporates the
material metaphors
with paper and kind of a
three-dimensional effect.
And it also
incorporates typography.
And so one of the sections
in the material design
spec I really recommend.
It's very-- it has a
lot of good information
and a lot of good guidance
about how to do to typography
within material design.
And of course,
another part of that
is a much greater, expanded
palette of different weights
and of different sizes,
and how you kind of use
the weight and size.
Instead of having just one
size of text, one weight,
use this to indicate
the structure
of your app, the structure of
the information in your app.
So the cornerstone of
typography in material design
is the Roboto 2.0 typeface.
And so this was an update
that happened in Lollipop.
And you know, it
was pretty subtle.
A lot of people probably
didn't even notice it,
but there was actually a
lot going on in this update.
So one of the things is the
expanded Unicode coverage.
It actually increased
by a factor of three.
And we have full
support for Unicode 8.0
for Latin, Greek,
and Cyrillic scripts.
And that covers a lot of the
languages in the world that
are maybe less familiar to us--
like the African languages use
a lot of unusual
Latin characters.
We also expanded the
weights and styles
that we ship on the device.
So we're doing thin, light,
regular, medium, bold,
and black.
So there's a tremendous
palette of the visual effects
that you can get.
And all of those
include true italics.
And we also have a
family of condensed,
which is better for better
information density,
and also can give
you some contrast--
two different styles that you
can work with in your app.
In addition, the Roboto 2.0
font is completely open source.
And that includes not just
the final TrueType font files,
but the entire bill chain.
So you can go in there and
customize it, and play with it,
and send us pull requests.
And we really treat
almost everything
we do in a very
open source manner.
So the design updated as well.
And this is just a little
bit of a before and after.
And you can see it's
a little subtle,
but there's kind
of a stiff sides
to some of the characters,
like a capital O.
that has become a more
refined, gentle curve.
Some of the shapes were
maybe a little bit unusual,
like the Ks and the
capital R. And those
have become kind of
more simplified and more
streamlined.
And we also went from
a square dot on the I's
and J's to a round dot.
So it's just--
it's an evolution.
It's a more refined form of
the original kind of design.
It's very central to Android
and very central, of course,
to material design.
So I talked about the
global reach of Android.
We talk a lot about
the next billion users.
And there are-- like we
heard in the previous talk
about how do you reach them
through the Play Store console,
but there's also a
lot that you have
to do with a presentation
of text and language
in these devices.
So again, Roboto
2.0 dramatically
increases the Unicode coverage.
And you can see this
is just a sample.
This is just one of the pages
of kind of additional extended
Latin characters.
And another thing
I'll point out,
just for this
slide, some-- if you
look kind of near the middle,
towards the left-hand side,
you see some Os with some
doubly-stacked accents.
And that's a very common
pattern in a lot of languages,
but not European languages
that we're used to.
So you see it in Vietnamese and
some of these other languages.
So you really-- when
you're designing your apps,
when you're testing
your apps, you really
need to be careful
to test them in some
of these other languages
to make sure that you've
got enough vertical space.
This is kind of one
the real key takeaways.
That if you just
design in English,
you've got these letters.
They don't have
anything going on above,
they don't have
anything going on below.
But that is not the experience
of millions-- hundreds
of millions of people
around the world.
So in addition to Latin,
Greek, and Cyrillic,
there's this huge diversity
of other languages.
And in fact, this is the list
of scripts, not even languages.
There's many scripts that
support multiple languages.
These are the Noto
scripts that we're
supporting in Marshmallow.
So it really is a huge expansion
compared with previous versions
of Android.
And it really covers a very
large fraction of the languages
that are spoken in the world.
And so here are three scripts
that I just kind of picked out
as representative.
I find these just
really beautiful.
And you can see a tension
between classical forms,
but also trying to make them
consistent with the kind
of clean Roboto design.
And so I think these
three are either
new in either
Marshmallow or Lollipop.
So then, in addition to this
kind of large set of scripts,
CJK-- Chinese,
Japanese, and Korean--
represent a very large
fraction of the users
of Android, a lot of
the users in the world.
And so in Lollipop, we
launched Noto CJK, which
is a joint project with Adobe.
So it's also out there.
They released it
as Source Han Sans.
And that's also an
open source project.
And it has a tracker.
It's very active.
People find issues and
it's being revised.
And in addition to just the
fonts, that project also
kind of brought with it
a higher-quality render
for something called
CFF-- Compact Font Format.
And this is based
on the Adobe code,
but it's now been open sourced,
so it's part of FreeType.
So you can go look at the code,
use that in your own projects
as well.
So Noto CJK is a very
ambitious project
that really is designed to
be a comprehensive support
font to support all of CJK.
And that includes the
different local forms.
So there's a difference between
simplified and traditional
Chinese.
Those are different
from Japanese,
and then there are
some glyphs that
appear different in Korean.
And it's very important
to these users
to see the correct
form in their language.
If you see it wrong, it's just--
it really is a polish problem.
So notice CJK has
a unified design.
There's like a consistent--
there are some releases
that we've done where the
Chinese and Japanese really
don't look like they're part
of the same family of fonts.
And in Noto CJK, we really
have a unified design,
but we have the
different variants
in the different regions.
So no discussion of
text is complete today
without talking about a Emoji.
And we really treat
Emoji as a type of text.
So an app doesn't have
to do anything special.
An app doesn't have to say, oh
show me some color images here,
or something like that.
You just represent text and you
ask for the text to be drawn
or in a text view or edited.
And it just automatically
shows up using this color font
technology, which is now
standardized in OpenType 1.7.
And there are
actually many tools--
many font editors,
actually, will create fonts
in this Emoji form.
So if you want to-- or I should
say in a color-font form,
whether it's used for Emoji
or not is really up to you.
And you can incorporate these
custom fonts in your app
and get color representation
of either Emoji or text,
just by dropping in the font.
This also supports
flags and keycaps.
It's a more expanded
set of Emoji.
And one of the new
APIs-- I should say this
is a Marshmallow API--
in a lot of apps,
you want to know what Emoji
are present, because you
want to make a decision.
Do you present this as a
palette for users to choose?
And this has always
been a problem,
because different phones will
have different Emoji sets.
And as we're upgrading,
it's hard to know,
is this Emoji present or not?
Or does this flag exist, in
the case of the flag Emoji?
And so we've got this new
API that will tell you.
It's very fast.
And we really
recommend-- we really
want you to be using
has glyphs so you
know what Emoji are on your
device, what you can use.
So then I want to
talk about some
of the typography features.
We've really been
expanding this.
The goal-- my goal,
certainly-- is
to make Android typography match
what you can do on the web.
And match what you can do,
not just in print, but really
high-quality print.
And so I'll walk you
through some of the things
that we do here.
I'll just go through
this list and then
I'll show some examples.
We have kerning and ligatures.
We've actually had those
since, I think, JellyBean-MR2.
But now, there's more control.
So if you want to
turn those on and off,
there's fine-grained
control to do that.
We have this font feature
settings attribute
where you really can go in and
control the OpenType features.
I'll give you several
examples of that.
And that's using a
CSS-compatible syntax.
So we want to make this stuff
so if your designers are used
to controlling
typography on the web,
we want to make kind
of impedance mismatch
as smooth as possible.
So you can just
take that knowledge
and apply it to Android apps.
And then this is a little
bit more technical thing,
but we use OpenType integrally
to give you these localized
forms that there are many
languages certainly not
just the Chinese,
Japanese and Korean,
where there's going to be
some subtle differences.
The same basic script,
but differences in the way
it's presented.
And we use OpenType
to control that.
And I'll talk a little
bit also about what
you want to do in your app
to make that work perfectly.
So kerning and ligature.
So the fi ligature is a little
controversial in Roboto.
Not everybody loves this.
But it is definitely
a sign of kind
of more sophisticated
typography that you don't just
put the letters,
that in some cases
you have these
combinations, and you
have a specifically drawing
glyph that represents
more than one letter.
And this is certainly--
this exists in Roboto.
And it's a very important
part, especially in Sara fonts.
You really need those
ligatures for the font
to display correctly.
So if again, as you're using
custom fonts in your app,
you want those ligatures.
And the same is
true for kerning.
You almost never want
to turn this off.
The only time you might
want to turn it off
is if you've got some kind
of technical alignment,
where things need to have the
consistent width, no matter
what the characters are.
But in any case, as of
m, with the font feature
setting attribute,
you can control these.
These are actually implemented
as OpenType features.
And as with any
OpenType feature,
you can turn it on or off
with font feature settings.
And that's actually
a Lollipop Plus API.
Another kind of
great hidden feature
is the use of proportional
in old-style numbers.
And these are really
important for a more refined,
sophisticated typography.
That the default
numbers are basically
the same size as capitals, And,
they're all the same width.
And being the same width
is really important,
if you've got some kind
of animated display.
You don't want it to be
juddering back and forth,
or if you've got kind of a
tabular presentation of numbers
like a spreadsheet.
But it's not always
the prettiest display.
And if you're
doing running text,
if you're doing
paragraphs of text,
then proportional may be a more
subtle change, where you just
give the one a
little bit narrower,
so you don't have all
this space around it.
And then if you're really trying
to do something that looks more
like a book, something
that looks more
like traditional
typography, then you've
got these old-style figures.
And those are in Roboto 2.0.
Those are present
in the font and you
use the Android font
feature settings
to select P-Num,
proportional numbers,
or O-Num, old-style figures.
And again, highly recommended
if you're bringing custom fonts
into your app that you have
the complete access to all
of the OpenType
features in those fonts.
And this is, again, an
[? L-Plus ?] feature.
Another feature that
I think is really
a powerful tool for bringing
more sophisticated design
to apps is control
over letter spacing.
So there's a default
letter spacing.
It's really tuned
for legibility.
People are getting
information on their phone.
They need to be able
to read it quickly.
And that's what the default
letter spacing is tuned for.
But if you've got
something that's
kind of larger,
more of a branding
and less of a
functional element,
then spacing it a little tighter
might kind of highlight that.
And then you can
also use wide spacing
as maybe a form of emphasis,
or just bringing a little bit
more breath to your design.
So you have-- you're
no longer stuck
with just the default spacing
that's set in your font.
And again that's an
[? L-Plus ?] feature.
So in Marshmallow,
this is really
one of the things I'm
most excited about.
That we really stepped
up the paragraph layout.
And the old algorithm kind
of used-- you fill up a line,
and then when once
you get to the point
where the line is full then
you just break at the word
boundary, and you keep going.
But in Marshmallow, we have this
high-quality paragraph layout
mode.
And it incorporates a couple
of different elements.
It incorporates
automatic hyphenation.
And it also incorporates
this concept
of whole-paragraph optimization.
So it kind of moves pieces
around to get a best score.
To get-- there's kind of
a score that tells you
what is the quality
of this layout.
And it's really trying
to optimize that
across the entire paragraph.
Both of these
algorithms are based
on Tech, which is a
print typography package.
It has a very long history.
And high-end, print-publishing
tools use this same approach.
But the parameters, you know,
when do you use hyphens?
Hyphens are a little bit weird.
People are not used to seeing
them on a mobile device.
There are some contexts where
they make a lot of sense,
like if you're displaying
an e-book for example.
And there are some
where maybe it
makes a little less sense
like UI strings or maybe chat
messages.
People are not used to
seeing hyphens there.
So we tuned the parameters.
It's heuristics.
And we kind of chose these
so that-- a couple of things
that people are noticing.
That if you hyphenate, and
you break a partial word
onto the last line,
that is really weird.
That's something that people
have a negative reaction to.
So there's a parameter in
the tuning that kind of
doesn't do that very often.
But on the other hand,
one of the reasons
why you want to do
this hyphenation
and want to do this
high-quality paragraph layout,
is you want better
information density.
This is especially
important when
you have very narrow
settings, like--
and especially true on very
small screens like watch faces.
That if you break a word,
and you leave a huge amount
of empty space, that's waste.
That's an opportunity that
you could have used that space
to present information.
So we really look at this
question of would hyphenation
bring you end lines down to n
-1 by doing the hyphenation?
And in that case, we say yes.
You do want that.
You don't want to
waste that space.
You want more
information density
and that increases
the chance that you'll
get a hyphen on there.
So this is kind of
a different tuning
than you would
expect for something
like print typography, which is
where there's kind of the most
tradition of doing hyphenation.
So one of the other things we
looked at is this question,
do we want to have an opt-in,
where your apps says, yes.
I want high-quality mode.
But maybe it's
considered expensive.
It's too slow to run, or we
don't want to always have it.
But we tried turning it on
across the entire system
as a default. And we
really liked what we saw.
I mean, you want a
higher-quality presentation
of paragraphs.
Of course, if it is
not right for your app,
then please turn it off or
control the tuning parameters.
But we also had to do a lot
of work on the performance.
So it's doing a lot more work.
There's a lot more
sophistication
that's going on in there.
But overall, the amount of time
that it spends drawing text
is about the same as Lollipop.
There's some use
cases that are faster.
There's some where it's-- where
maybe some of the benchmarks
where we've gone backwards.
But we've really tried to make
that usable for everybody.
And so here's a kind
of a demo of the kind
of profound difference that
you can see, that you really
see on the left-hand side, which
is the Pre-M paragraph layout.
And you can still get to this
by setting break strategy equals
simple in your XML.
But you see these huge gaps
where the word conversation,
it doesn't fit.
So OK, it just goes
to the next line.
And with the
high-quality layout,
it says, OK we can
hyphenate that.
And we can actually
get this block of text
that's very clean.
It really looks much
more like a book
and less like kind of
computer text display.
And on the right-hand
side, you can
see it's actually pretty
eager to use hyphens.
And that's a control.
There's a default, which
is a little less eager.
It uses hyphens when they really
improve the density, when you
really improve those huge gaps.
And then there's this setting
of full hyphenation frequency
equals full, which is really
appropriate if you are
displaying paragraphs of text.
If you've got an app
like an e-book reader
where you're really
displaying paragraphs,
then we really recommend using
full instead of the default.
And if you want to
turn hyphenation off,
you can actually mix and match.
You can have a
high-quality strategy,
in terms of the optimization
of where the line breaks go,
but just no hyphens.
And that's another option.
In the same kind of increase
control, enhanced control
over line breaking,
we were looking
at this particular problem--
a very common pattern
for UI strings.
You've got a string
that just doesn't quite
fit into this space, into
the width of the set.
And then you get this word,
you know UI strings are often
very short.
So this happens like quite a lot
where you just have one line,
but you have like one
or maybe two words
that go to the second line.
And it just doesn't look nice.
It's not a very pleasing visual
presentation of this text.
So you can select break
strategy equals balanced.
And that tries to line it
up so that all of the lines
are the same-- are
roughly the same length.
In a traditional paragraph, you
try and get all of the lines,
except for the last,
the same length.
But balance just really
just tweaks that one thing.
And so it's just make
this whole thing line up.
This is based--
again, for designers
who are familiar
with web technology,
this is based on Adobe's
proposal for text wrap balance.
That hasn't become a standard.
I don't think it's
widely shipping yet.
But again, we're trying to
make the design of typography
on Android similar to the design
of typography for the web.
So I wanted to
also-- I mentioned,
when I was talking about
the different languages
and the kind of different things
that we do to change the way we
present text, that
this is really
one of the most important
things that apps can do
is to get the locale of the
text that the app is displaying
correct, because if
it's wrong, things
will be-- you'll still
get the text displayed,
but things will be degraded.
They won't be as nice.
They won't be as polished, as if
you set that locale correctly.
So there's three
different ways that
locale all flows into
text in Android--
in Android framework text.
There's the settings,
which are system-wide,
which control a default locale.
And of course, this
is their fault.
This is what happens if
you don't do anything.
And you hope it's right,
but unfortunately, there
are a bunch of cases--
mostly when you
have multilingual users.
In America there aren't any,
but in the rest of the world,
there's a lot of people that
speak more than one language.
And so the language that
they're viewing the app in,
the language that
they're interacting,
that they're maybe looking
at user content might not be,
might not match the
system setting app.
So we have a set text
locale API, which
you can use on a text view.
And if you know, if
you have metadata,
if your server knows the
language that that text is,
then we strongly recommend that
you set text locale on the text
queue that displays that text,
so that the locale is correctly
identified.
And then this may be a
little bit more specialized,
for something like a
translate app, where
you may have a
single string that
contains multiple languages.
It might say the
translation of this word
into this other language
is some other word.
And you might have a
language that's just a span.
And for that, we have
got a locale span
and you can set that on
just the text in your app
that represents that span.
So what does a locale do?
I mean like I've said,
it's important to set it.
But what happens?
How does that actually control
the way text is displayed?
And before JellyBean, there
was no difference at all.
Text just displayed.
But in Marshmallow,
there's four different ways
that locale affects the
presentation of text.
It changes the
font that's chosen.
And that's especially
important for distinguishing
between traditional
and simplified Chinese,
as well as Japanese and Korean.
Those are different
fonts that are unified.
It affects this local
OpenType feature look up,
so that there are differences
in Devanagari script
between Hindi and Marathi.
And it makes sure that
you get the correct forms
of those letters, things
like Persian numerals
and so on or not-- well, Persian
numerals are complicated,
but the point is that if
you know the language,
then setting it will
get the correct look
ups to happen on the font.
The locale also
affects line breaking.
There are some
languages where deciding
where the boundaries are
between words-- where
you can break the
line-- is actually
kind of a complex question.
Thai is the most
common, certainly,
that you'll see where
there's no spaces.
And so you really, in the case
of Thai, you need a dictionary.
You need to say,
this is the word,
so that I know where the
boundaries of the words are.
And that is completely
reliant on knowing
what the language is.
If you just put Thai text
through, but don't identify
that the language is Thai,
then it gets confused
and you get in line breaks in
potentially very bad places
that don't line up
with words at all.
And then of course,
lastly, now that we
have automatic
hyphenation, that knowing
which dictionary of patterns
to use depends on the language.
And this is, like
most of the things
that I just talked about are
kind of more exotic languages
to this audience.
But automatic hyphenation
is important between,
for example,
Norwegian and English.
They're both in the
same script, but if you
use the wrong patterns, you'll
get you'll get weird hyphens.
And then like there's-- how do
you know what the language is?
And fortunately there is
an open source library.
I mean, this is actually
mostly developed by Google,
but it's out there.
The Compact Language
Detector library,
which is now in
its second version.
It's open source and is designed
to be very performant, very
fast.
It's not a huge
dependency to take on.
So if you've got an app where
you're displaying messages,
and you really don't
have the metadata,
you don't know where it came
from, what that language is,
but you want to ensure that
it's displayed with the highest
quality-- and of
course, that metadata
can be really useful for
lots of other things--
then we really do recommend
this compact language detector.
And that'll-- you pipe the
output of that into set-text
locale.
And that really improves
the quality of your display.
So that's kind of all of the
prepared topics that I had.
I want to open it
up to questions.
I'm happy to answer
any questions you have.
And please wait for
the mic to come to you.
AUDIENCE: On the
topic of custom fonts,
so you doesn't dance via
simple view, such as text view,
but it's pretty difficult to
do for framework UI classes
such this such as like
navigation view or toolbar.
Is there a recommended
way by the frameworks
team to achieve like custom
fonts globally within your app?
RAPH LEVIEN: Yeah,
that's a good question.
I don't think we have a
mechanism for applying
a font globally across the app.
So unfortunately, I
think that is something
that you have to do with code.
But that's something that
we're interested in looking
at, making easier.
AUDIENCE: I get a lot
of requests from design
for situations where they
want the text to be exactly
this size-- possibly because
it's aligning with an image,
or something like that.
What I'd really like to do
is have the text shrink down,
if it's in, say, a language
that has more text there.
What is your
recommendation for that?
RAPH LEVIEN: That's a
very common request.
And we do not have support in
the framework for that yet.
It is something that we
are really looking at.
There are a number of
open-source libraries.
One of the reasons that we
haven't implemented something
like that-- I looked at it.
And one of the problems
that you get into,
is that you get, kind
of, how do you specify
what that behavior should be?
So you just specify, kind
of, one point in there
where you want it to
be exactly that size.
But there's a lot
of other use cases
where people are
trying to-- you know,
because you're
trying to line it up,
basically, with other
graphic elements.
There's a lot of other cases
where people are just mostly
concerned about making it fit.
So they want kind
of different logic.
They want something
that says, make it
a standard size make it 14sp.
Unless that doesn't fit.
And then we--
whoops, excuse me--
and then we want to have it
shrink down to some other size.
But we don't want to have it
shrink down to below eight,
because then it
becomes illegible.
So you get use cases
where specifying
how you want that behavior to
scale is kind of complicated.
And that's kind of-- if and
when we do implement something
like that in the
framework, we really
need to make sure that we
cover the range of behavior
in a way that makes sense.
Until then, I'm not
going to recommend
any specific
open-source library,
but there's a bunch
of them out there.
And it's likely that
there's something
that just
sub-classes-- you know,
text view and overlays
that behavior.
That there's-- it's likely that
there's something that will fit
what you need.
AUDIENCE: Early
on, I saw a mention
for CSS styles being
applied to text.
Is that something that's
done through styles?
Or is it through the
use of HTML text?
RAPH LEVIEN: OK.
So I'm sorry if
that was misleading.
It's not CSS styles in general
that we're applying to text.
That there are
specific attributes,
there are specific parameters
and that we're-- and in that
particular slide, I was talking
about font-feature settings.
And it's like the syntax,
because specifying
all these OpenType features
is kind of a complex thing.
It's not just like a number
or something like that.
And so we adapted
the syntax from CSS.
It is compatible with CSS.
So if you have that particular
feature, other features
that we've got like
letter spacing, the name
of the feature, the
meaning of the future,
we're trying to make
it consistent with CSS.
But we haven't implemented a
web browser in Android framework
text.
You can use web view, but
that's-- there is not a generic
CSS translator.
It's just the
specific features that
are low impedance or
compatible with CSS.
AUDIENCE: What is
the performance cost
of the high-quality text layout
strategy with hyphenation?
For example if you like want
to actually change the text
view contents, so
what is that going
to cost you at lay out time?
RAPH LEVIEN: Well,
measuring text performance
is really complex.
I mean the order of
magnitude is that it's
about the same as
simple text in Lollipop.
So it's doing more work, but
we actually took a wrench to it
and did a lot of optimizations
to make it go faster.
There's going to be some
specific cases that are
going to be a little slower.
There's other cases,
like for if you're
editing a very large
buffer, that it's
going to be a lot
faster, because we really
did a lot of them performance
improvement in that area.
So ultimately, if you're really
concerned about performance--
like if you've profiled your
app and you've said oh my god,
I'm spending all of this
time doing the layout
of the high-quality layout.
And if you've decided that
the visual improvement of that
is not worth it in your app,
then by all means set simple.
We have not come across-- I
can't really think of any apps
that I know of,
either first party
or third party, where people
have felt a need to do that.
But it's certainly an
option and we will continue
to improve the performance.
This is a very
important area for us.
It's got to not jank.
AUDIENCE: Also, will there be
a support library for this?
RAPH LEVIEN: No.
Unfortunately, a
lot of the stuff
that happens in framework
text is at such a low level
that you can't really fill
it in with a support library.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I know better than
to ask you what
you guys are going
to do in the future,
but I wanted to ask a
little about static layout
and the new method that lets you
set custom margins per line--
RAPH LEVIEN: Yes.
AUDIENCE: I know it's not
ready to do full wrapping
around a path, which is
what I imagined when I first
heard about it.
But I am wondering,
what were you guys
imagining when you added it?
Is it just the
circular watch face,
or is there something
else cool I could do
about it that I don't know yet?
RAPH LEVIEN: Oh, great!
No.
And that's a slide that
almost happened in this talk,
and I wanted to keep
it simple, because I
wanted to talk about things that
would be for most developers.
So certainly the circular watch
face-- so maybe I should just
explain that there's
layers of the text stack
where text view is the one
that most of you interact with.
But underneath the text
view is static layout.
And static layout does
a lot of the things
around line breaking
and paragraph layout.
And then below that is
draw text and the kind
of very low-level APIs.
And in static layout,
we have a new method
that lets you adjust
the shape by controlling
indents on the paragraph.
And so yes, the watch
face was absolutely
a motivation for that.
We are seeing
other applications.
People are adopting
it in cases where
people are doing custom
views, rather than
just relying on text view.
One of the really nice
ones is when you just
get to flow around an image,
where you're basically
doing something like
a web-style float.
And it is possible to do your
own-- to kind of roll your own.
If you've got a
path, to figure out--
based on the knowledge
of line heights and stuff
like that-- to figure
out what the indents are.
I think you'll see this
continue to evolve.
Clearly, it makes sense to do
a higher-level feature that
has kind of easier to
use, is not so low-level.
But unfortunately,
it is not there yet.
Any other questions?
All right.
Well, thank you so
much for coming.